The fourth
most common misconceptions
about Islam amongst the non-Muslim,
it is Islam was spread by the sword.
What is the meaning of the word Islam?
Islam comes from the root word salam
which means peace. It's also derived
from the Arabic word silm which means to
submit your will to God. So Islam means
peace acquired by submitting a will to
almighty God. So when the media says
Islam was sped by the sword, it means
peace
acquired by submitting a will to God was
sped by the sword. It means peace was
sped by the sword. Isn't it
contradicting?
Can peace be spared by the sword?
Islam is generally against violence
against force but as a last resort to
maintain peace. Islam gives permission
to use force or violence. And we know in
every country you have a police. This
police has weapons. Many a time uses
force against criminal who are there to
disrupt the peace of society. So when
every country has a police force where
the country allows them to use force or
violence against those people who
disrupt peace. So similarly Islam as a
general policies against violence,
against killing, against force, but as a
last resort. If somebody wants to
disrupt the peace and the serenity, then
Islam as a last resort gives permission,
allows a Muslim to maintain peace, they
can use force.
And to dispel this misconception
that Islam was fed by the sword, if you
read the book by Delesia Olyeri, I'll
quote only one paragraph from his book
Islam at the crossroad. He writes in the
book Islam at the crossroad on page
number eight dile
he mentions that the legend history
makes it clear. He says, I'm quoting,
"History makes it clear that the legend
of fanatical Muslims sweeping across the
world, forcing Islam at the point of the
sword over conquered races is the most
fantastic absurd myth that historians
have ever repeated. I would like to
repeat this paragraph. Di
a very famous historian write in his
book Islam at the crossroad on page
number eight. He mentions and he writes,
"History makes it clear that the legend
of fanatical Muslims forcing Islam at
the point of the sword over conquered
races is the most fantastic absurd myth
that historians have ever repeated. When
we learn from history, we know that the
Muslims we ruled Spain for about 800
years. Later on the Christian crusaders
come and they kill most of the Muslims.
There was not a single Muslim
who could openly give the adan.
They come and kill the Muslims.
We Muslims
we ruled India for about a thousand
years. The Muslims ruled India for a
thousand years and they developed the
country. When the Muslims ruled India,
it was the most powerful country in the
world.
25% GDP of India of the world was only
India's GDP. When they came okay we
ruled India with love with compassion
with justice and we developed the
country which became the most powerful
country the most richest country in the
world. We ruled for a thousand years the
Britishers they come to India in their
historical books. Oh, we came to spread
modernism, technology, peace. They come
to India and they loot India. They rob
India. They take all the wealth, all the
jewels from India and they put so much
of taxes. And in their historical books
you read, oh, they have come to spread
peace, technology. They came to rob the
country. The GDP went so low. Today,
where is India? Where is India today?
At that time we were the richest country
in the world because the Indians when
the Muslims ruled India they developed
the country. They bought peace. They
brought prosperity. Wherever they went,
there were prosperity.